elle est très courte mais voilà comment
j'ai découvert que mon copain me trompe
et il ya quelques années
d'accord ça faisait quelques un petit
moment qu'on était ensemble ça marche un
petit peu moins bien donc je dit il est
un petit peu coquin ce soir là j'avoue
et de le tromper et donc de faire venir
quelqu'un dans l'appartement et je
reconnait on va être un peu vulgaire
rappelant qu'une ça marchait moins bien
donc des suites de faire un plan un peu
ce soir là l'ami arij dans le cher de
robin je sais moi oui bah oui mais
pardon j'ai étudié cheminées rené
brisach
écoute moi bien parce que ce que je
racontais là est vrai ouais la personne
arrive garçon arrive un grand
appartement juste que tu veux si tu veux
amer il refait sa com samedi mais je
connais ça parte et après tu te raconter
leur horrible mais comment ça tu connais
tu n'as pas ton mais là oui je peux tu
l'a loué avant qui me serait impossible
m'appartient j'avais 10 ans et mon
appartement
voilà je suis désolé parce qu'ils ont
des chiens désolé je suis célibataire
avec moi j'ai fait un plan cul dans sa
partie avec voilà c'est comme ça que
j'ai découvert que en réalité mon copain
de tromper des chiens c'est par où
commencer
et le mec maintenant ils devenus
[Applaudissements]
ces fûts mais les fans d'histoire mah
costumes incroyables a complètement
folle vraiment complètement folle bravo
bravo ou mathieu c'est la meilleure
histoire à celle de mathieu